right okay let's go
started let's go right fingers yet neat
you have together a onion
now don't worry about chopping this
onion too far they're gonna speak we're
gonna quit on Jesus huh
now Tony swimming we're making a soup
not a mess right no don't worry about
trying to talk that to finally because
we're gonna blend the soup vacations
together Wow brushes our bacon together
and just cut that into lovely strips
now the secret a long-simmering cream
lovely and just right straight just just
cut through different yes okay well and
don't worry about it being too fieger's
you'll be blended right pan is hot turn
that gets up to maximum oil in the pan
you're not sure it's hot touch it all in
the pan right
that's the Johnny way don't bond Oh
Johnny rice okay I put the oil in the
pan for you
right bring your pan to the board okay
right and put the onions of the bacon
yeah not where you want to what I was
gonna be mad stir that okay
now little seam calculator
all right salt now written important
don't worry about putting pepper in
there because we use the watercress to
make it nice and peppery now no pepper
so only yes yes now once I stood you
know I'm guess how could you say oh I'm
so sorry
right ah yes advancement ambience like
up unbelievable right get you a bunch of
mint right stay with me boy
yes come on yeah scissors okay and give
that a little trim basically trim around
the stalks okay now again don't worry
about the stalks if Johnny can do this
anybody can do it come on stay with me
that's all you want left now sweat the
mint down with the bacon and the onions
don't worry about the color but just
sweat it down nice and slowly fresh Peas
yes
ready Kevin good good back I wanna make
good sweat round now somebody's like to
let the face came to the bottom I go ok
said economy meal oh do you wanna Ricky
was the last thing he cooked at home
last yeah I come to home person ah bozo
Amy's a parfait
yeah we're close - yeah he's doing the
couch judge attend an extra then Kenya
Hey like a bad pass oh yes right no I
can do it and expose it what how'd you
do it what is granny one new way me
water cook a portion eggs right
obviously the punishment day you warn
the kissing the water close